bonjour monsieur côté
tout d'abord mes condoléances je vois
que c'est sale et l'émotion elle est là
c'était quelqu'un que vous aimiez
beaucoup jean marc vallée vous aimiez
l'homme vous aimiez le cinéaste
qu'est ce qui le démarque site
je vais essayer de ne pas craquer
d'abord faire une entrevue descente avec
ma voix qui chevrote armes parce que
j'ai beaucoup de clem c'est un choc pour
moi ce matin vraiment
incroyable j'étais extrêmement tassia
jean marc vallée pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord c'est un être charmant grâce née
à sts et j'ai eu la chance de jouer dans
son premier long métrage est tout de
suite après l'histoire il m'avait dit tu
vas voir je vais j'entrais d'écrire
quelque chose tu fait capoter tu veux
jouer le père dans une saga familiale
tu vas adorer ça et ça a pris il ya
écrit avec françois muli nous c'était
l'histoire et ce à prix 5 à l'écriture
et après quatre ans de financement ou à
chaque année il m'a appelé en me disant
si tu as d'autres prochain fallait parce
que c'est pas d'alger retrouver le
producteur j'ai pas encore les sous et
une année en 2004 il me dit ça y est
retourne et et à chaque année au moins
on se voyait ou deux fois par année
riche en invités au restaurant bon il me
racontait des anecdotes d'hollywood et
me raconter sa vie et ce matin je pense
moi je viens d'une famille de trois
garçons j'ai eu deux garçons ça faisait
5 comme dans crazy et ce matin je pense
à emule et la lex et je vais parler à
m'ouvrir les autres années jean marc oui
et multijoueur zachary le le petit le
rôle de marc andré grondin jeune et
c'était je l'avais j'étais toujours avec
lui c'était comme dit est devenu presque
comme mon fils pendant trois mois et je
viens de parler à mon fils max est là
c'est sûr que ça vient nous chercher
parce que ça nous fait réaliser que la
vie va vite et il ya des imprévus comme
ça comme sans maladie sans rien sans
prévenir la faucheuse vient nous
chercher
et ça l'a surpris effectivement tout le
monde j'aimerais parler à l'acteur en
vous c'était commande d'être dirigés sur
un plateau par jean marc vallée
j'adorerais ça d'abord ces textiles
quelqu'un qui nous laisse énormément de
liberté
ce qui était particulier de jean marc
c'est que souvent les réalisateurs vont
me dire ça va très bien
si ça va pas je te le dirai mais lui
jean marc
même quand ça allait bien il ne te dire
j'ai ça va bien et ça quand tu te couche
le soir plus de succès une grosse
journée le lendemain que ton réalisateur
vient 2010 ça va bien c'était bon t'es
bon tout va bien
alors ça c'est dans le positif total
c'est pas juste quand ça va mal combien
te le dire mais lui il ya d'auray les
acteurs y est il était d'une attention
particulière au jeu des acteurs vraiment
et une petite anecdote à un moment donné
je me sentais tellement bien dans ce
rôle là qu'une journée j'ai dit et il me
semble vraiment que
je joue plus je joue pas peut-être que
je vais trop je vais te jettes mauvais
je ne sais pas il m'a dit non non non tu
en fais pas qu'en fait pas continuer
comme ça tu votre bon fais moi confiance
parce que j'avais l'impression de
docteur d'être tellement dans le rôle
que j'avais plus l'impression de jouer
et il m'a rassuré et puis je suis
tellement content d'avoir fait ce crime
la paix en 2005 on en a profité tous les
deux on a voyagé beaucoup on est allé
partout à marrakech à madrid à mexico
pour faire la promotion du film qui a
été vendu dans je ne sais pas combien de
pays 90 pays je crois et c'est un film
universel sur l'acceptation des autres
c'est un message d'humanité
extraordinaire
on va essayer de reprendre votre image
jamais ses côtés justement le frame le
film crazy a été marquant pour la
carrière de jean marc vallée mais
également pour vous je crois oui ben oui
parce que c'était notons que si c'était
vrai mais année ça on a entre 2000 et
2020 j'ai la chance d'avoir une très
belle carrière et cuisine a sûrement été
une des raisons c'est sûr que quand on
peut toucher à des déroule comme ça dans
des films qui ont eu autant de succès
c'est bon c'est vrai tout cet apprêt
liste noire donc le premier film dans
lequel vous avez participé avec jean
marc vallée vous avez dit qu'il avait un
immense talent et qu'il ira loin est ce
que vous êtes surpris de son parcours
aussi fulgurant
non je suis pas surpris du tout ce qui
m'impressionnait surtout c'était sa
capacité de communiquer dans la langue
de shakespeare parce que moyen dalmat
mon anglais était loin d'être aussi bon
que le sien et je me disais qu'ils c'est
formidable de réussir à je suis toujours
impressionné par ces dunes par denis
villeneuve quand jean marc barr si ces
réalisateurs qui rit c'est ça les fera
juste s'exprime en anglais mais aller
chercher larmes l'âme des personnages et
de leur transmettre transmettre ou aux
comédiens anglophones ce qu'ils veulent
dire exactement et et sa vision des
choses et son amour de la musique
jean marc hamy
dark heresy je pense que tout son
salaire pour avoir la muse et dont il
rêvait et et satee je crois une des
raisons aussi qui fait que cette crise a
eu tant de succès space oddity les
rolling stones charles aznavour la cité
qui résonne et il se mêlait de tous il
choisissait mais grave at
oui qu'est ce que tu penses de celle là
alors qu' on y va pour cela tous les
petits détails de jeu d'accessoires de
techniques et il était et est encore
entouré d'une équipe avec marc côté
closes et les effets spéciaux
c'est un grand réalisateur c'est une
énorme perte pour le spo nos seulement
le cinéma québécois pour le cinéma une
internationale vous avez vraiment de
très beaux souvenirs on espère que son
approche rend en inspirer d'autres
encore une fois mes sympathies michel
côté je rappelle que vous êtes acteur
vous avez joué dans deux films de jean
marc vallée
liste noire et crazy merci énormément et
moi qui vous remercie bonne journée au
revoir